hey what is up guys
mkbhd here and welcome to your first
look at the iPhone 11 Pro and the iPhone
11 Pro max so the Roman numerals are
gone and these are Apple's new flagship
iPhones so there is already a video up
on the iPhone 11 the much less expensive
iPhone for the masses that I think most
people will be buying that'll be the
first link below the like button I go
over all the new features and the more
basics and things like that these new
phones are nine ninety nine and ten
ninety nine to start and they go up from
there so they're very expensive and they
also put pro in the name which I have
mixed feelings about I get it
but I have mixed feelings about it ok so
what is new well you can clearly see the
design is already nearly identical to
the 10s and 10's Macs same sizes so
there are really four main things you
need to know here display battery
cameras and the matte finish actually
start with the matte finish that's it's
the most obvious the glass on the back
of these pro iPhones is now this sort of
frosted I would say a very slight
texture and a matte finish to it and I
absolutely love it and then the camera
square weirdly goes back to glossy so
it's like the opposite of the cheaper
iPhone 11 which is a glossy phone with a
matte camera square I just kind of wish
the whole back of this phone was matte
but maybe that's just me they don't have
a matte black but they do have a matte
Space Gray along with a midnight green
which is like this subtle dark green
almost military camo type of green and
then there's a silver which looks very
bright and gold which is the most
familiar one so yeah matte dark grey
well it actually might scratch more
easily not sure yet only time will tell
I gotta use the phone and put his
through its paces but matte dark grey I
think first impression love that
okay so display now if you told me
there's gonna be a new iPhone pro this
year with a pro display I would just
assume that you meant it was gonna have
120 Hertz high refresh rate promotion
display it does not have that but it is
a bit of an improvement from the iPhone
10s
so it's now even brighter bringing a
peak brightness up to a ridiculous 1200
nits and creating a 2 million to 1
contrast ratio so awesome numbers and
it's the same resolution OLED same sizes
same notch and everything very
familiar-looking display but it's now
even more impressive for watching movies
and editing photos and videos that type
of thing it's a better screen 3d touch
is also now gone but I and I think many
others weren't really using it much
anyway and it's replaced with long
presses instead of pressure-sensitive
presses they're called haptic presses
and they do pretty much all the same
things they're calling this new display
super Retina display XD are so if you're
into name-dropping
you can call it that I'm just gonna call
it a brighter display then there's the
battery so on stage Apple claimed 4
hours more battery life than the iPhone
10s and on the the 11 Pro max 5 hours
more battery than the 10s max that is a
huge improvement and as really isn't
coming from much physically larger
battery from the previous phone a lot of
these improvements are coming from the
improved efficiency of the a13 Bionic
chip inside so not only is it a much
more powerful chip like we said in the
iPhone 11 video but it is much more
efficient too and that's where your
battery games will come from I mean of
course I will have to test these claims
and put it to use and see how good it
really is but I'm really happy about
those claims of much better battery life
and speaking of power it now comes with
an 18 watt fast charger in the box
finally iPhone Pro it took a while it
took a pro phone to get that but if you
want that fast charger in the box the
iPhone 11 the cheaper one doesn't get
that and it is USB type-c to lightning
so yeah step in the right direction so
that's the matte finish the display and
the battery which brings us to the one
thing that they spent by far the most
time on and that's the new cameras so
triple cameras on the back here for the
iPhone 11 pro and pro max it joins the
three camera Club so one normal camera
one 2x telephoto and 120-degree ultra
wide and you can switch between the
three of them in the
with the buttons if you want or with a
slider that sort of gracefully moves
between all three focal lengths and they
made a big deal about how they wanted to
match the quality as well as possible
between these three cameras which I
really hope is true that sounds great
you can do 4k 60fps video from all three
cameras which is dope and you can choose
to do portrait mode from either the
telephoto or the normal camera which is
awesome I'm definitely going to choose
portrait mode from the standard primary
camera way more often now that I'll have
that choice and yet we can just
generally look forward to better images
and better videos coming from
computational photography high dynamic
range and all sorts of image pipeline
improvements that make this quote pro
level photo and video camera and then
there's a couple other little things I
mentioned in like in the last video like
better face ID and slightly improved
water resistance and a little bit more
shadow resistant glass but aside from
that that's basically it for the iPhone
11 pro so when you hear that you don't
necessarily think oh there's a whole ton
of things at all stacked and added up to
make this worthy of a pro level name but
it really just feels like they added the
pro name because that's what's hot right
now maybe that's a maybe that's a rant
for a whole nother video but like all
these other features they could have
added that would have made me think it's
fine to name it pro aren't there like
there's no reverse wireless charging
there is no high refresh straight
promotion display there is no USB type-c
that would have been kind of pro there
is no Apple pencil support there is no
in display fingerprint reader there
isn't even any like special little bits
of software that are tossed in to the
pro version to make it at least feel
more Pro kind of like they did with iPad
OS on the iPad pro like if you're not
gonna do any of that Apple you know what
I've at least felt a little more Pro on
the pro iPhone but you have a big camera
focus on putting the camera settings in
the camera app instead of keeping them
buried separately in the Settings app
little things like that possibly the
most basic thing they could have done
really here to show that they're
thinking about pros that take all kinds
of photos and videos but that's not here
either so it's not like yeah it's not a
bad phone at all honestly this is
probably going to be one of the best
performing phones of the whole year
might have some of the best battery life
of any phone this year and on top of
that it'll probably
have one of the best displays and I just
frickin love that and that finish but I
guess it's just my expectation of the
word Pro that makes me feel like I
should expect a bit more on top of that
but I guess that's just me that's just
the way I feel
bottom line here is this to sell you
this phone Apple is banking on you
wanting to take the best photos or
videos of any phone they want this to be
the best camera in any smartphone it's
clear from the presentation and any ad
you watch and if you take a lot of
videos I think it will be now for photos
that's debatable
you know the pixel 4 is right around the
corner while ways new flagship is about
to come out so that's a tougher sell but
this this Pro iPhone upgrade is all
about these cameras and as a camera nerd
I do love that even if it looks like a
kitchen stove on the corner of your
phone either way let me know what you
think also definitely check out that
iPhone 11 overview video for a feature
overview and to see all those sweet
colors but that's been your first look
at the iPhone 11 Pro thanks for watching
this one and I catch you guys later
peace